Let's do a psychology experiment.
Let's show our audience a scene
consisting of eight shots
and the story it tells is suspicious
but a little ambiguous
and open to interpretation.
A girl's in her apartment when a guy
walks suspiciously past her window.
She goes outside to check it out.
After the video,
we ask our audience
a couple open-ended questions
and see what they think about it.
How did it make them feel,
did they like it,
did they not like it,
stuff like that.
Now let's show that same video
to a different audience
but change one thing.
Mirror every shot
so now every movement left-to-right
becomes right-to-left.
The question is, does this
edit change anything?
Does character direction affect how
the audience perceives the character
or the entire scene as a whole?
The answer is yes, and a lot
more than you think.
But why does it matter which way he went?
To understand why direction
change is so important,
we have to talk about the
three axes of movement.
There are three directions on screen
a character can move.
Right and left, up and down
and forward and backward.
The direction a character moves
matters in a scene.
Moving towards the camera shows
power, domination and aggression
and moving away shows weakness.
Similarly, characters being looked
down on appear weak
and high up characters are
much more dominant.
"Now my evil power will be unlimited!
"Can you feel me?"
- "I can feel you."
- "Whoo!"
These two explanations make sense.
Of course someone low and
far away from the camera
will be perceived differently from
someone high up and close.
[Child screams]
[Monster starts screaming as well]
But the final character movement,
lateral movement,
going from right to left,
is a lot less obvious.
What makes one side of the screen
different from the other?
Why does movement
right to left matter?
The answer comes from
time and language.
In Western culture, left to right
indicates the progression of time.
Our language reads from left to right.
Books begin from the left and finish
once we get to the right.
In video games, players
start on the left side
and finish the level on the right.
On any line graph, time increases
as we move right.
In our everyday life,
movement towards the right
indicates time, progress and normality,
and movement towards the left
indicates moving back in time,
abnormality and regression.
From this thinking came the theory
amongst film scholars
that people will interpret
left-to-right movement
as more natural and normal than
right-to-left movement
because of how our brains naturally
process moving images.
And this idea of time and normality
in left-to-right movement gets applied
in a variety of films.
For example: Lord of the Rings maintains
its left-to-right movement
during the journey from the Shire
to Mount Doom.
Left-right movement is maintained
during the big travel shots
and it's a subtle visual to
indicate the clear goal
to reach a specific destination.
Compare that clear objective
to the last scene in Full Metal Jacket.
It consists of two shots.
One shot of soldiers moving
left to right past burning buildings,
and another shot of them
moving right to left
with burning buildings still
in the background.
The abrupt lateral direction change
makes it look as if they
randomly switch directions,
and it gives the implication that
the soldiers are wandering aimlessly.
Stanley Kubrick uses lateral direction
change to make some commentary
about the army's unclear objectives
and perhaps commentary on the
Vietnam war as a whole.
Lateral character movement
can also tell a story.
In one scene in Full Metal Jacket,
soldiers move to the right
towards some combat
zone off-screen
and wounded soldiers get carried
away from the combat zone,
moving from the right
side to the left.
There's a subtle visual
reinforcement here
that where the soldiers headed off-screen
is where men get brought back wounded.
This lateral technique is similarly done subtly
in Platoon and Saving Private Ryan.
[music plays, indisctinct voices talking]
"Wade!"
- "Yes, sir."
- "See what you can do."
So left to right is observed
as positive, progressive and normal,
or at least that's what many
film theorists assumed.
It's only in the last five years or so
that researchers started
empirically testing lateral movement.
In 2012, Cleveland State University
conducted an experiment
by showing a sequence of eight
shots to a group of people.
They showed the exact same shots
to another group of people,
but reversed all left-to-right movement
to right-to-left movement.
Each group answered
several specific questions
and several open-ended ones
about how they felt after watching.
The results confirmed what
many film theorists had assumed
but had never had any hard
evidence to prove.
The experimenters analyzed open-ended
questions for key words.
For example, 24.8% of responders used
"anxious," "nervous," "uneasy," "suspenseful"
to describe the video
and 11.9% said "fearful," "frightened" or "scared."
The most statistically significant difference
between the two groups
was what the experimenters
called "the negative effect,"
similar phrases including "didn't like the clip,"
"liked the clip," "good," "bad," "interesting," "boring"
and "strong" and "weak" were
the phrases that differed
the most between the two videos.
So for the left-to-right video,
members consistently used words
like "good," "interesting" and "strong,"
while the ones who saw right-to-left,
used words like "bad," "boring" and "weak."
Audiences perceived left-to-right movement
positively and right-to-left movement negatively.
This study provides a huge
opportunity for film makers.
By something as simple as
switching character movement,
a director can instill a negative
or positive emotional response
on the audience.
But it seems some directors have
already caught on this difference
in left to right and right to left,
going as back as Alfred Hitchcock.
Alfred Hitchcock's Stranger on a Train opens
with the protagonist and antagonist
showing only their feet and legs walking.
They walk towards each other,
as if to imply their paths will eventually cross.
If our study is true and left-to-right movement
is preceived as more positive than right-to-left,
then this opening scene has
already subconsciously established
that the right-to-left character
is an antagonist
and the left-to-right character
is a protagonist.
So not only can left-to-right movement
indicate a progression of time,
it can even indicate something
positive or negative.
Roger Ebert fully supported the idea himself,
as he explains in his 2008 article
"How to Read a Movie."
Roget Ebert goes further to say
even the left and right sides of the screen
are perceived as either more
positive or more negative.
A character on the right feels
more positive and in control,
while the one on the left seems
weaker, perhaps more sinister.
This is a common recurring theme:
right – good, left – bad,
and various filmmakers use this technique.
"Master's my friend."
- "You don't have any friends."
"Oh, come off it."
- "You come off it!"
- "You."
- "You infinity."
- "Ahhh!"
Ebert makes the claim that
these conventions of right and left
extend beyond our language and culture.
He says that in all his years of watching movies,
Asian cinema uses similar left
versus right techniques.
And the study supported this belief,
religious belief, right or left handedness and race all
did not significantly affect the
audience's perception of lateral movement.
Of course there are no absolutes in filmmaking
and sometimes what's contrary
to the rule works just as well.
But either way, this study shows that
there really is a difference
between left and right in film.
It's only so recently that any empirical testing
on film techniques has actually been conducted.
Roger Ebert's claims, while convincing,
were only speculation at the time,
but have now been proven to an extent.
I contacted Cleveland State University,
the ones who published this study,
and they're still currently conducting experiments,
testing film theories on audience members.
It's really exciting to see that
even after a hundred years,
we're still learning new things
about filmmaking to this day.
What was once speculation has
now been followed up with concrete evidence.
So the next time a character crosses
the screen, ask yourself:
"Where did he go?"
- "Come on!"
- "Which way did he go?"
- "Where did he go?"
- "I don't know, he took my
clothes and went that way."
- "Come on!"
Thanks for watching, I wanted to clarify
the video experiment that I show
isn't the original video experiment.
The original one hasn't been
published yet; it hasn't been posted,
although they published the article,
they haven't posted the video that they used.
So I just took what they talked about
in the article and I recreated it.
I encourage you guys to look at the original article
it's amazing, it goes very in depth,
it talks about things I didn't talk about,
I'll link it in the description,
also I talk about film theorists in the video
and I don't refer to specific names,
but really I'm referring to Kuleshov.
He's the man, he's been doing
all this film theory stuff.
In the seventies, he was coming up with these–
this three axes of movement theory,
and how people interepret movement in film
and so I encourage you to look him up,
I'm going to add some of his
writing in the description as well.
Thanks guys.